[Music]
the much anticipated movie the Marvels
is finally here and a lot of people have
been waiting for this one seeing as it's
a sequel to the Captain Marvel movie and
also to both Disney plus series W
Division and Miss Marvel there is plenty
of Marvel to unravel here so to make you
feel marvelous here's everything you
need to know before you go see the
Marvels so as we team up with the
Marvels today here's what we're going to
cover a quick recap of all the titles
that led up to this followed by a look
at the Glorious cast then a bit about
what you can expect the story to be
about and of course who was responsible
for bringing it to the big screen hint
she's pretty groundbreaking so strap
yourself in like it's Carol danver's Jet
and get ready for takeoff you ready H
further faster baby that's right okay so
let's all Marvel at what's happened on
some past Marvel projects starting with
Captain Marvel you don't remember
anything when we first meet Brie
larsson's character she already has her
Cosmic Powers but has lost her memories
and she's working as an elite Warrior
for the cre who are Waging War against
the shape-shifting Scrolls now after a
mission gone wrong she crash lands here
on Earth in 1995 I mean that scene when
she lands on a blockbuster lives rentree
in my head get it rentree cuz you had a
rent videos a
blockbuster anyways and learns that
she's actually Carol daners a human
pilot that was given amazing gifts now
this news comes courtesy of Maria Rambo
and her young daughter Monica Rambo who
revealed that Carol was actually once
like family to them Carol eventually
comes to find out that she's been duped
into fighting on the wrong side of a war
and she flies off to help the Scrolls
rebuild now a mid- credit scene brings
Carol up to 2018 AKA a more current
timeline to go with the rest of the MCU
when she appears looking for Nick Fury
everyone's always looking for Nick Fury
where's Fury and that opens up our next
portal to Wanda Vision so this show
about Elizabeth Olsen's Wanda Max moff
and Paul BET's Vision features the pair
living an ideal Suburban life until they
aren't because nothing is as it seems I
mean we should all know that by now I
think something's wrong
here it was Agatha all along sorry I
couldn't help myself now one of the
supporting characters and someone who
eventually helps Wanda in the end is a
now grown up Monica Rambo and we learned
that she is actually followed in her
mother and Carol's footsteps to become
an Air Force pilot and later joined the
Counter Intelligence Agency s now she
was also a victim of the snap from
Avengers Infinity War AKA Thanos and his
big hot dog finger wiping out half of
humanity for 5 years I don't feel so
good I'm still not over it and it's when
she came back and rejoined sword that
her paths basically cross with Wanda now
by the end her multiple passages through
a radiation field they call the hex
eventually Alters her cells and gave her
superhuman abilities like spectral
Vision energy absorption intangibility
you know all the ingredients to make you
a badass pretty much and because life is
always better with a third wheel or so
my friends tell me when I'm around let's
take a quick look at Miss Marvel we're a
team no no no no no we're not a team
we're not a team so in this certified
fresh show we met Kamala KH played by
Aman balani the first person by the way
with no prior acting experience to be
cast as a lead character in the MCU so
you two can be an Avenger my friend I'm
a superior now so that's normal in the
show she's a 16-year-old struggling to
fit in who also happens to be a total
fan girl of The Avengers especially
Captain marble and then she gets powers
of her own and things quickly change as
she grows into her new life a mid credit
scene in the final episode further ties
Miss Marvel and Captain Marvel together
as the pair suddenly switches places
leaving Carol danver's in Kamala con's
family
home what is happening to me so before
we jump into what the movie is about
let's get a little more familiar with
the cast we know about Brie Larson tiona
Paris and Aman valani I am so excited
excited to see this Trio in action but
we also know about a few others like
Samuel L Jackson once again rocking the
eye patch as Nick Fury brush off another
Disney Plus show Marvel is a secret
Invasion and that's about wait for it a
squirrel Invasion we also know that
British actress Z Asen is playing the
big villain of the film darb Ben who is
a cre accuser and has a serious bone to
pick with Captain Marvel in the trailer
she is shown to have a Universal Weapon
which can transform matter so she'll be
a formidable Foe for these three
superheroes parasite co-star parksun
will be playing rinse yon in the film a
good guy and maybe even a love interest
for Carol daners oh please yes now
Kamala con's dad mom and brother from
Miss Marvel played by Mohan Kor Zenobia
shraf and Sager Shake respectively will
also return for the marbl and sure it's
good knowing who's going to be in it but
the real fun actually comes with seeing
the people that you didn't know about
which I cannot wait for can I see some
identification please beers cre Star
Force we don't carry our identification
on little cards so what exactly is going
to happen in the actual movie you ask or
I ask at least well footage from d23
showed that the film picks up after
those previously mentioned events from
Miss Marvel with Carol and Cala
switching places from there the trailer
reveals that those two and Monica Rambo
keep switching places every time one of
them uses their powers the director
since confirmed that that is because of
a mission Captain Marvel did that
brought her close to some sort of
abnormal Wormhole and the big baddy darb
Ben is also going to be a pretty serious
Force to deal with she is using that
powerful weapon we talked about and
targeting as Carol says in the trailer
quote every planet we call home which is
not cool it is pretty cool though fun
fact that zo's fiance is Tom hson who
plays lowkey making me feel like I am
really going to love her villain
too little over the top don't you think
I thought it was spot on and finally
let's check out The Talented folks who
put this whole thing together director
Nia dasta is making history as the first
black woman to helm a Marvel film of
course she's used to making history by
now though after becoming the first
black female director to debut at number
one at the box office with 2021s
Candyman she also co-wrote the Marvels
along with Alysa kosi who has worked on
the show lowkey Megan McDonald who wrote
for w vision and then you got Zeb Wells
who worked on Robot Chicken I love this
we'll take
it man where all right friends we did it
that is everything you need to know
before you go see the Marvels and
theaters November 10th now
you understand my name is as Perez
thanks for watching and be sure to rate
and review this film at Ron tomatoes.com
I'll see you guys next
time